all right give you a quick update on the
Herschel Walker Rafael Warnock runoff
December 6th of course in Georgia this
will determine not who controls the
Senate Democrats have taken control of
the Senate it is currently 50 to 49 but
that race that runoff will determine is
it a 50-50 senate for two years where
Kamala Harris is the tie-breaking vote
for Democrats or will Democrats have a
51-49 majority which at least takes care
of Joe manchin or Kirsten Cinema without
requiring Kamala Harris's tie-breaking
vote Herschel Walker continues to speak
and it becomes increasingly clear every
time he does
that he doesn't have any idea what is
going on Herschel Walker held it's it's
truly Beyond parody at this point in
time Walker Walker held an event in
which he I think he's trying to attack
Raphael Warnock here
but he really is criticizing himself
you'll see what I mean in a moment here
in this first clip Herschel Walker
addressing the issue of keeping one's
own kids keeping one's own kids and then
he even paid himself a child care all
that stuff why don't he keep his own
kids don't have nobody to keep your kid
you keep your kids he's got somebody
else keep me I keep my own even though
he lied about me it's okay it's okay
because he's trying to get your vote
don't let him trick you try to get your
vote
what is Herschel Walker talking about
right there
is Herschel Walker saying that Raphael
Warnock should parent his children
because one of the things we learned
about Herschel Walker is that he's been
an absent father to multiple kids or am
I make trying to make more sense of it
than we can make listen to this again
what is he talking about and then he
even paid himself a child care all that
stuff why don't he keep his own kids
don't have nobody to keep your kid you
keep your kids then you got somebody
else give me I keep my own even though
he lied about me it's okay it's okay
because he's trying to get your vote
don't let a trick you try to get your
vote how can you hear that and think
that's someone who should be making
decisions about what our tax rates
should be
that's somebody who I would want to be
one of 100 votes for the entire country
as to decisions on foreign policy it
just doesn't make any sense literally it
doesn't make any sense here's one more
clip at another event where Herschel
Walker yesterday is I mean I guess I
don't even know how to report on this I
guess he's trying to make the case that
he would be a good Senator fundamentally
that's what this is about and he
attacked the green agenda and said that
we should continue having gas guzzling
cars and it's not clear whether he
doesn't understand gas guzzling is a
pejorative or whether he likes it you
know some of these people love the idea
of damaging the environment they sort of
take pride in it they say it's manly and
patriotic listen to this and again
try to make heads or tails out of it I
promise you
[Music]
you agenda I'll raise my hand right now
but we're not ready right now so don't
let them fool you like this is a new
agenda this is not a new agenda we're
not prepared we're not ready right now
what we need to do is keep damn those
gas guzzling cars so we got good
emission under those cars we're doing
the best thing that we can but we need
help we need help and those other people
not helping us China's not helping us in
here not helping us but yeah we're gonna
do it all because they spending your
money
doesn't make any sense I know that most
of those words are English but it
doesn't make any sense and the hope is
if Herschel Walker's lack of
qualifications are made clear if
Herschel Walker's hypocrisy on so many
issues is made clear
and if we do the door knocking and we do
the phone Banking and to the extent that
you do need to raise money in order to
win a senate seat people donate to
Raphael Warnock hopefully this goes in
warnock's favor I continue to say
it would be such a massive humiliation
to the country to the country to see
Herschel Walker be a senator
that we really need to pull out all the
stops and prevent it from happening and
by the way we're going to be up against
Kelly Lefler you tell me whether that's
scary or not if you have a friend or
loved one who is passionate about the
environment here is a perfect holiday
gift our sponsor established titles is a
project that lets you ceremonially
purchase as little as one square foot of
dedicated land in edelston Scotland so
that you can call yourself a lord or a
lady like the historic Scottish
tradition some people even change their
plane tickets or credit cards to include
Lord or lady your title pack comes with
an official certificate you can see
exactly where your plot of land is
located it makes a perfect last minute
gift but most importantly established
titles plans one free tree for every
plot of land sold established titles
does really good work all over the world
with reforestation organizations like
one tree planted and trees for the
future so you'll have a great laugh
whether you're Scottish or not I'm not
but you're giving the gift of
reforestation to fight climate change if
you use my link you'll get 10 off and
your plot of land will be right next to
mine you can see it on a map go to
establishtitles.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman for an extra 10 off on top
of their Black Friday deal the link is
down below